You can send it down.
Wir haben einen Notruf
wegen häuslicher Gewalt erhalten.
(Mann über Funk) 1-2-5-4-2-9.
Take care, alright? Alright.
Urs Brechbühler aus Zofingen
wollte sich weiterentwickeln.
Wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte,
dass ich mal Polizist
in Amerika werden würde,
dann hätte ich gesagt: "Ja, an
dem Tag, an dem es Frösche regnet."
Nun wird er Polizist in New Orleans.
Eine Stadt, in der die Kriminalität
zwar zurückgeht,
die aber immer noch
zu den gefährlichsten der USA zählt.
An jedem dritten Tag
wird hier jemand getötet.
Do you have any weapon?
- (Mann) I have no weapon, man.
Okay, stay here.
Alright. Do you understand that I
have to place you under arrest?
An der Polizeiakademie in New Orleans
geht es heute lockerer zu als sonst.
Es ist der letzte Schultag.
(Mann) Go, go, go!
We need them gone.
Go, go, go! Keep going, keep going!
Dieser beginnt mit einer Tradition:
einem Lauf, der die
Zusammengehörigkeit festigen soll.
(Mann) Forward march!
Urs Brechbrühler
reiste für die Aufnahmeprüfungen
dreimal nach New Orleans
und schaffte alle acht Testphasen.
# I'm gonna be a running man.
(Im Chor) I'm gonna be a running man.
# A running man.
- (Im Chor) A running man.
Er besitzt die Green Card,
die Arbeitsbewilligung,
und jahrelange Berufserfahrung.
* Sie singen ein Soldatenlied. *
Er arbeitete u.a. während fünf Jahren
bei der Regionalpolizei Zofingen.
Der Schritt nach New Orleans
ist für ihn schnell erklärt:
Es hat ein wenig mit meiner Frau
zu tun. Sie ist Amerikanerin.
Ihr gefiel New Orleans gut.
Wir waren mal
hier in New Orleans am Jazzfest.
Damals sagte jemand:
"Komm doch zum NOPD,
zum New Orleans Police Department!"
Ich lachte darüber, schaute mich
in der Schweiz und hier um
und entschied irgendwann,
mich hier zu bewerben.
Dann ging es plötzlich
Schlag auf Schlag.
Nun bin ich hier.
Während 28 Wochen
wurde er an der Akademie gedrillt.
Erlaubnis, einzutreten.
Open your ears and close your mouth!
Listen up! Tomorrow ...
Neu für den 35-Jährigen
waren v.a. die amerikanischen Gesetze
und der Taser,
die Elektroschockwaffe.
Am härtesten war es,
als er sich einem professionellen
MMA-Kämpfer stellen musste.
Ich musste einen Raum betreten, in
dem sich zwei MMA-Fighter befanden.
Das Ziel war einfach ...
... 3 Min. irgendwie durchzustehen.
Man wusste nicht, gegen welchen
der MMA-Fighter man kämpfen muss.
Aber es war sehr intensiv,
sehr schwierig und dann war es ...
Es war ein bisschen ....
Es war knapp,
wie er mich in den 3 Min. besiegte.
Come on!
Er erhält die Polizeidienstmarke.
Bruce Willis.
Thank you, Sir.
Sie haben in etwa seine Grösse.
Und fast denselben Haarschnitt.
Thank you, Sir.
Der Spitzname Bruce Willis
ist für ihn ein Kompliment,
die Dienstmarke
ein Symbol seiner Leistung.
Sind Sie auch ein bisschen stolz?
- Ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Es war nicht einfach
für einen Schweizer.
Die 34 Rekruten versammeln sich
ein letztes Mal für die Diplomfeier.
Ihre Familienangehörigen
sind eingetroffen,
unter ihnen Ehefrau Rachel.
Morning everybody.
- (Im Chor) Morning, Sir.
Good morning.
Der Polizeichef und
die Bürgermeisterin bedanken sich,
dass sich die Rekruten
in den Dienst der Stadt stellen.
Ich möchte mich
auch bei den Familien
für ihre Unterstützung bedanken.
Ich verspreche, dass wir
euch nicht alleine lassen werden.
Wir werden an eurer Seite sein.
Ihr seid uns wichtig.
Thank you so much.
* Applaus *
Hier ist sie.
Hello.
Danke fürs Kommen.
* Rachel lacht. *
Good job.
* Kuss *
Ich bin sehr, sehr stolz.
Wir nannten
Brechbühler Bruce Willis,
da uns seine Art und Leistung
an den Schauspieler erinnerten.
Es war eine grossartige Erfahrung,
mit ihm zu arbeiten,
seine Verhaltensweisen
kennenzulernen
und ihn die Polizeiarbeit in den USA
zu lehren.
Es war spannend zu sehen,
wie er die Erfahrungen aus seiner
Heimat an das Neue hier anpasste.
* US-Nationalhymne *
We solemnly swear ...
- (Im Chor) We solemnly swear ...
... that I will support ...
- ... that I will support ...
... the constitution ...
- ... the constitution ...
... and laws of the United States.
- ... and laws of the United States.
Die Spezialauszeichnung
für den besten Notendurchschnitt ...
... Officer Urs Brechbühler.
* Jubel *
Nun ist er offiziell der klügste
Polizeibeamte seiner Klasse.
Eine Auszeichnung - das freut mich.
Juhu.
Das sind gute News.
Aber seinen Namen
haben sie falsch geschrieben.
Sie haben das H vergessen.
Polizist zu sein, begeistert Urs.
Er geht gerne zur Arbeit,
er ist interessiert und neugierig,
was auf ihn zukommt.
Klar mache ich mir Sorgen,
aber er ist glücklich.
Jeden Tag arbeiten zu gehen
und glücklich zu sein -
mehr kann man nicht erwarten.
Und dass er eines Tages
nicht mehr nach Hause kommen könnte?
Ich bin auf jeden Fall besorgt.
Aber ich nehme
das Leben Tag für Tag.
Sein neuer Arbeitsort New Orleans:
Die Kriminalitätsrate
sinkt jedes Jahr, dennoch ...
Ich glaube ...
... letztes Jahr gab es über
200 Tötungsdelikte in New Orleans.
Das ist verhältnismässig viel.
Ich denke, wenn jemand sagt,
er habe keine Angst,
ist er wohl nicht ganz ehrlich.
Man muss einfach lernen,
seine Angst zu kontrollieren,
und man muss eine gewisse Vorsicht
an den Tag legen.
Dann wird alles gut.
Das Gefahrenpotenzial ist hoch,
v.a. auch, weil Urs Brechbühler
nach der Ausbildung
oft alleine auf Patrouille ist.
Die Familie ist sein Leben.
Quack.
What's that? Sheep. Bäh.
Die Militär- und Polizeidienste
sind für den gelernten Polymechaniker
eine Berufung.
Er war mit der schweizerischen
Friedenstruppe im Kosovo
und wurde ein Experte
in Kampfmittelbeseitigung,
Entschärfung von Minen und Bomben.
Ich bin ein logisch denkender Typ,
ich will helfen und bin sehr genau.
Das ergab sich einfach so.
Das eine führte zum anderen
und ich war plötzlich
in einem Fachgebiet sehr gut.
Er war so gut, dass er in Afghanistan
Blindgänger und Minen im Hochgebirge
und auf Landwirtschaftsfeldern
entschärfte.
Sie müssen sich überlegen:
Man begibt sich in ein Kriegsgebiet,
in dem man
nicht besonders willkommen ist,
und entschärft dort Bomben.
Wer tut so etwas?
Das ist das Gefährlichste
bzw. das Risikoreichste,
das ich bisher getan habe.
Aber ich würde es wieder tun.
Allerdings mit Vorbehalt:
Ich würde es wieder tun,
wenn ich keine Familie hätte.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Heute Morgen beginnt das nächste
Kapitel seiner Ausbildung:
Er geht auf Streife.
Nun gilt es ernst.
Wenn man zur Tür rausgeht,
sollte man keine Angst haben,
dass heute der Tag ist,
an dem etwas Schlimmes passiert.
Man muss es
einfach im Hinterkopf behalten.
* Er entsichert die Waffe *
Dem Gedanken, seine Familie
nicht wiederzusehen, weicht er aus.
Man verabschiedet sich
jeweils trotzdem.
Okay.
Bye.
- Love you.
Hab einen guten ersten Tag.
Oh, ja, er wird legendär sein.
Alright, bye.
- Bye.
Während 18 Wochen
lernt Officer Brechbühler
nun in verschiedenen
Stadtbezirken sein Handwerk.
Morning, Sir.
- Hey. - Sir.
Dienstantritt: 7 Uhr morgens.
I'm Field Recruit Brechbühler, Sir.
Have a seat.
- Yes, Sir.
Der Lieutenant betont einmal mehr,
dass jede Aktion korrekt sein müsse,
und dass die Körperkamera
jeden ihrer Schritte aufzeichne.
Be your determinant of ...
Dann wendet er sich
Urs Brechbühler zu.
Wie viele Sprachen sprechen Sie?
Schweizerdeutsch, Französisch ...
Schweizerdeutsch ist eine Sprache?
- Ja.
Weiter spreche ich ein wenig
Russisch, Serbisch, Kroatisch
und verstehe ein wenig Spanisch.
Ich denke, das wird genügen.
Dann geht's auf Patrouille.
Streifenpolizisten
fahren zu Notrufen.
Brechbühler trifft seinen Ausbildner.
Guten Tag, Sir.
- Christian. Wie heisst du?
Brechbühler Urs.
- Brechbühler Urs? Alright.
Er arbeitet im French Quarter,
wo jederzeit alles passieren kann.
# Halleluja, by and by.
# I'm flowing.
One more time!
Ich erwarte jeweils nichts vom Tag.
Ich bereite mich aufs Schlimmste vor
und hoffe aufs Beste.
Das ist das Interessante
am Polizistenberuf:
Man nimmt es, wie es kommt.
Der erste Notruf.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Was hat
die verdächtige Person gestohlen?
Sie suchen eine verdächtige Person,
die etwas gestohlen haben soll.
Officer Risseli weiss,
um wen es geht.
Ich kenne ihn seit Jahren.
Wenn du super aggressiv wirst,
wird auch er super aggressiv.
Das ist meine Erfahrung mit ihm und
vielen psychisch kranken Personen
und von denen haben wir hier viele.
Ah, da ist er. Right here.
Where are we at?
Wie geht's?
Also, ich kläre nur mal ab,
was Sache ist.
Falls alles okay ist,
lassen wir dich sofort gehen.
Bis dahin lege ich dir
Handschellen an. Steh auf für mich!
Umdrehen!
Geht's zum Stehen?
Es ist keine Verhaftung,
sondern eine Festhaltung.
Watch your head, watch your head!
There you go.
Alright. One foot in.
Hey, die Handschellen sind zu eng.
Die sind schon gut so.
- Nein, verdammt, sie tun weh.
Dein Arm tut weh?
- Ja, Sir.
Ich sehe, was du meinst.
Lass es uns anders probieren.
Ah, das ist das Problem.
Wir lösen sie ein wenig.
It goddamn hurts, man.
Besser?
- Viel besser.
Let's roll, Sir.
Officer Brechbühler lernt,
jeden Schritt zu protokollieren.
Wir gehen von hier bis dorthin
mit einem Mitfahrer.
Es ist anfänglich etwas verwirrend.
* Der Verdächtige
spricht unverständlich. *
I'm gonna show you.
Der Tatort.
Der Verdächtige soll hier
mehrmals für Unruhe gesorgt
und letzte Woche
etwas gestohlen haben.
Die Verkäuferin identifiziert ihn.
Es war am Donnerstag,
die Kamera hat ihn aufgenommen.
Viel Aufwand
für Pralinen im Wert von 8 $.
Sie geben ihm eine gerichtliche
Vorladung und lassen ihn frei.
Zurück auf dem Revier.
Ein Afroamerikaner braucht Hilfe.
Im Gegensatz zu anderen US-Städten
scheinen rassistische Übergriffe
von Polizisten
hier kein zentrales Thema zu sein.
Was man mir als generellen Wert
mit auf den Weg gab ...
Im Unterreicht
wird einem vermittelt,
dass man unvoreingenommene
Polizeiarbeit leisten muss.
Man sollte jemanden nicht nur
aufgrund äusserer Merkmale,
z.B. aufgrund seiner Hautfarbe
oder seiner Religion beurteilen.
Man sollte jemanden
fachlich beurteilen.
Alright.
Es läuft aussergewöhnlich wenig
an seinem ersten Tag.
Die Schicht ist zu Ende.
Und, wie ist dein erster Eindruck?
- So weit, so gut.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Es verstreichen zweieinhalb Monate.
Er wechselt in andere Bezirke und
bearbeitet nun viele Gewaltdelikte
wie Raubüberfälle, Schlägereien,
häusliche Gewalt, Morde.
Er muss den Taser einsetzen
und die Pistole ziehen.
Ich denke,
dass ich in den letzten Monaten
auf der Strasse
relativ viel gelernt habe,
v.a. dass Eigenschutz
sehr wichtig ist.
Da andere Patrouillen
länger weg sind
oder da man nachts
alleine unterwegs ist,
ist es wichtig, dass man darauf
achtet, einander zu unterstützen.
Man muss
auf viele Details achten ...
... damit man hier
ein guter Polizist sein kann.
Sein neuer Ausbildner
arbeitet seit 27 Jahren hier.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass du die Kultur kennst
und verstehst, worüber sie reden.
Die Leute hier
haben z.T. keine Ausbildung,
aber im Leben auf der Strasse
sind sie gewieft.
Als ich anfing,
wurden wir Polizisten respektiert.
Aber jetzt sind
die Kriminellen verrückter
und schiessen auf uns -
mehr denn je.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Der erste Notruf.
Sie werden als Verstärkung
bei einer Schlägerei gebraucht.
(Frau) Brechbühler,
gehen Sie auf die andere Seite!
(Mann, wütend) Get out my face!
I was doing it myself.
(Wütend) Get out! Get out!
Tellin' you to move.
Denken Sie, dass Sie im Ernstfall
wirklich auf eine Person
schiessen könnten?
Ich denke schon.
Und wie würden Sie damit umgehen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Das kann
ich nicht so klar beantworten.
Aber ich würde sagen, wenn es zu
einem Schusswaffeneinsatz kommt ...
... hätte ich wohl
kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Dann wird es sich wohl
um eine Situation handeln,
in der es auf gut Deutsch heisst:
"Er oder ich."
Entweder knallt
der böse Bube mich ab
oder ich
verteidige mich entsprechend.
Der nächste Notruf.
Officer Brechbühler ermittelt.
Ausbildner Mel LeBeaud beobachtet.
Es geht um häusliche Gewalt.
Ausbildner LeBeaud schaut,
dass alles korrekt abläuft.
What's the charge?
- (Brechbühler) The charge?
Wir sind uns einig,
dass er wegen häuslicher Gewalt und
Körperverletzung festgenommen wird.
Was ist der nächste Schritt?
Du weisst es nicht?
Ich weiss nicht genau,
was du willst.
Es geht nicht darum, was ich will,
sondern, was das Gesetz
in dieser Situation verlangt.
Okay, stay here.
(Mann, wütend) That's fucked up.
Sie verstehen,
dass Sie verhaftet sind?
Das ist abgefuckt. Sie lügt.
Ich lese Ihnen Ihre Rechte vor.
Sie haben das Recht zu schweigen.
Ab dem 21. Lebensjahr
ist das Tragen von Waffen erlaubt.
Officer Brechbühler muss immer damit
rechnen, dass eine gezückt wird.
Nebst Verkehrskontrollen
ist das Risiko
bei häuslicher Gewalt am grössten,
dass Beamte verletzt werden.
Die Leute sind
in ihren eigenen vier Wänden.
Sie wissen,
wo sich die Küchenmesser befinden
und wo sie ihre Pistole aufbewahren,
falls sie eine besitzen.
Wir dagegen wissen das nicht.
Wenn wir
ein solches Haus betreten ...
... sollte nicht nur einer reingehen
- das sollte man
sowieso nie tun -,
sondern manchmal
sind zwei Beamte nötig.
Man muss einfach
aufmerksam und wachsam sein.
Wenn man jemanden sieht,
der eine Waffe trägt,
braucht man
nicht sofort in Panik zu geraten.
Dies ist hier
z.T. ein alltägliches Bild.
Es geht Schlag auf Schlag:
Die Meldung ist, dass ...
... eine Person
mit einem Metallstück bewaffnet ist.
Da ist jemand im Hinterhof.
Ein Mieter ging mit einer Eisenstange
auf den Hausbesitzer los.
Wir reden mit ihm.
Sometimes talking helps.
Alright.
Ist jemand da?
Ich sah jemanden nach hinten gehen.
Anyone there?
* Spannende Klänge *
Wahrscheinlich ist er abgehauen.
Ich sah ihn vorhin.
Seine elfmonatige Ausbildung
ist bald zu Ende.
Als ich die Akademie
zum ersten Mal betrat, wusste ich,
dass ich jeden Tag
etwas lernen werde.
Das ist bis heute so geblieben.
Im Grossen und Ganzen ist es so,
wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe,
obwohl man in diesem Beruf
täglich überrascht wird.
Es gibt Tage,
an denen es mein Traumjob ist,
und es gibt Tage, an denen ich
lieber einen anderen Beruf hätte.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Aber an allen Tagen ist für ihn am
wichtigsten, dass er nach Dienstende
unverletzt nach Hause
zu seiner Familie kommen kann.